(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] God I love your dress.
- Fun!
- [Kelly] Have a seat.
- Whoa!
- Kelly, maybe we'll convince
you to move to New York.
- I know.
I'm just, I, we literally
have been here for a month.
My kids love it!
- Awgh!
- My son.
We, we go over the bridge
and he just yells freedom.
(Hilary laughs)
I don't know why.
He loves it here.
I don't know what he,
I don't know why but-
(Hilary laughs)
- Because it's the greatest city on Earth.
- [Kelly] It is a really beautiful city.
(Hilary laughs)
- Thank you!
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] And you walk right around,
and there's so many different languages,
and the parks are all
beautiful. People are playing.
- There's so much for kids to do!
- We have seasons here.
- [Kelly] Girl!
- I mean, I'm just saying
you could have snow.
- Everybody's like LA's
weather, it's amazing.
And I'm like, you, it does not rain.
(Hilary laughs)
It doesn't.
You get one thing and
it's sun, but it's great.
It's just like a lot of no season.
- Well we're just happy you're here.
[Kelly] Aww. Th...
- [Chelsea] We are.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] I'm very happy to be here.
I love we, we did this last year
and we were like, let's do it again.
It was so much fun, but
how was your summer?
Mine was awesome.
[Hilary] Was it awesome?
- [Kelly] Yes. Yes.
- Well, we're still in summer.
I mean, you know.
[Kelly] Oh.
- We're still enjoyin' it.
You're working.
- [Kelly] Well don't brag.
- I know. I mean.
Wow.
We've had a great time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Chelsea] Yeah.
- You know, we have, she has three kids,
therefore, I have three grandchildren!
- Yes.
(audience cheers)
- And I'm very excited about that.
- Do you, do you notice?
I don't know if you have the
same phenomenon in your family,
or if anyone here in your
audience, like my mom's like
so Chelsea's had a great summer,
but let me tell you
about my grandchildren.
(Hilary laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh, that's that's
what's so great though.
I love hearing grandparents
talk about kids.
- I've fell down the leader board.
(Hilary and Kelly laugh)
Like, I mean like a few days
after our daughter was born,
who's our oldest.
She's now seven.
I, I hung up the phone and I
remember turning to my husband
and being like, I just
had a whole conversation
with my mother and she
never once asked about me.
- [Kelly] No, that happens with all of us!
- And like Charlotte
was like four days old.
There's not that much to
say about like four day old.
- She's new.
You've been here.
- Oh yeah. Yeah.
We've gotten to know each
other over the last few,
know, decades.
- [Chelsea] I know.
- You have no new stories.
- [Chelsea] Have we?
- She does.
- I mean, I'm like, yeah.
You know, she can't do anything
yet, but she's awesome.
And now of course, thankfully
our three kids do a lot,
and so there's a lot of stories to share.
- Three kids.
That's a lot.
- Yeah.
- That's a lot.
- Well, we we've been on a road trip
for our season premiere,
so what was your favorite
road trip like as a family?
- Oh.
- [Chelsea] Ooh.
- We've had so many road trips.
- Once again bragging. No big deal.
- One, one of my really
favorite ones was when
Chelsea was about two years
old, and we lived in Arkansas,
and we got into the car, you
know, remember road trips?
I mean real road trips.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- In the car for days,
and off we went, we went to visit friends.
We went, you know, out to the East Coast.
We went up the coast.
We ended up, actually, in
New York and it was just
so much fun.
And the pictures from that
trip when she was just
this little kid and all of
it was a new experience.
- Yes.
- We stayed, you know, at a
place in South Carolina where
it, you know, we kept
saying there are alligators
in that water.
And I don't know whether it scared you,
and scarred you for life or not, but-
- Think I'm all right.
- Yeah.
- Yeah
- Think you're okay.
That's one of my favorite memories.
- [Chelsea] Yeah.
- Yes. Really.
- I have this vivid memory
when I was a little bit older
and we would drive to South
Carolina, you know, for
for vacations.
And we would stop at this
like pirate-themed restaurant
- In Savannah, Georgia.
- And I just have these-
- I remember it.
- like wonderful memories
of like the pirate themed restaurant.
And then my parents would be,
like, there are other
places like we can go.
(Hilary and Kelly laugh)
Like, but why?
- [Kelly] Why would you do that?
- [Hilary] Would would we ever want to?
Are there are there pirate costumes
for me to put on while I wait for my food?
If the answer is no, I'm not interested.
- My son, this is no joke.
I can't even believe you're saying this.
He dresses as a pirate daily.
He's obsessed with pirates.
- [Chelsea] Does he a have a pirate name?
- He's like, he likes Peter
Pan, but he dresses as Hook.
He likes being Hook.
(Hilary laughs)
I dunno, the foreshadow,
the foreshadowing.
- Very, very complicated.
- Very scary foreshadowing, but yeah.
- Many dimensions inside him.
- He loves it.
He just loves having the hook or whatever.
But I, I wanna show this cause'
Hilary posted this vacation
throwback and I love this.
(Hilary laughs)
- [Kelly] I, my kids we
love, is this Disney?
Is this Disneyland?
That where y'all are?
- [Chelsea] Oh yes.
- [Hilary] Oh yes, that was Disney.
That was fun.
- [Kelly] I mean we go so often.
It's so great.
- [Hilary] It is.
- [Chelsea] It's great.
- But we had we had trauma.
We had trauma on our trip because-
- Every family does.
There's always a breakdown.
- Well, and, and you know, we,
I think you were about four
as I recall on that trip.
- [Chelsea] Yeah.
- And so we were taking a
shortcut behind, you know,
one of the buildings
where the staff, you know,
took breaks, and out walks Goofy,
(Kelly gasps)
and takes off his head.
- No!
(audience gasps)
- [Hilary] This was-
- I was very confused.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- It was just really, this was
an earth-shattering moment.
- We, we did, we spent
hours trying to explain,
and it was like, oh, okay.
So, that's not the real Goofy.
The real Goofy is somewhere else.
This is somebody who's filling in.
- [Kelly] Good job.
- Yeah, we tried.
Right?
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- Or that like that anyone
maybe could be Goofy.
Like, my parents were really just throwing
every possible explanation.
(Hilary laughs)
- This is exactly what I do.
I know you have to do it with your kids.
I, I'll tell you backstage
how I ruined Frozen
for my daughter.
And I just, I didn't get that
she didn't know that
animation wasn't real.
It was just very sad.
(audience claps)
Speaking of road trips, here
is the poster for the new show.
I loved it.
I'm not kidding.
I was so mad at myself cause'
I, I literally like was
taping my eyelid.
I was like, I was like,
you must stay awake.
It is so powerful.
It's so important.
It's inspiring,
And it it's just an incredible thing,
And everybody else, maybe hasn't seen it.
So maybe tell them
what, what was the idea?
Why did y'all start this?
- Well, so we had written
The Book of Gutsy Women
a few years ago, which
really was the continuation
of a conversation we've
been having my whole life
about inspiring a dynamic and gutsy women.
Some in my life, my grandmothers
were both incredibly
gutsy women.
- Yeah.
- To women that my mother
kind of brought into my life,
to women whose stories
she would share with me,
her being inspired by Helen
Keller and Harriet Tubman,
and then as I got older Kelly,
I got to return that favor
bringing inspiring gutsy women who I knew,
kind of to my mom's attention.
So we wrote this book, and then
we had the chance to turn it
in to a series with Apple TV
Plus and understandably, Kelly,
like they were like, you
have so many amazing women,
many of them are not with us any longer,
so we have to kind of expand
kind of the, the window
of who we're looking at, so
that we can actually, you know,
talk to the women that
we're gonna feature,
and have shared experiences,
whether, you know, painting-
- [Kelly] That's helpful.
- with Megan Thee
Stallion or going kayaking
and canoeing with a
former white supremacist
which was one of the more-
- [Kelly] that was such
an intriguing episode.
- extraordinary moments we had,
to going to a comedy show to listen
to these amazing gutsy women,
you know, tell jokes on stage.
And so it just, it really it,
it at times was a literal road trip,
at times it was a more metaphorical one.
Hello COVID, and yet it was
such a joy and a privilege to
be able to learn these
gutsy women stories,
share these gutsy women stories,
and spend time with my mom.
(Hilary laughs)
(audience claps)
- Absolutely.
Well, and I, I want,
I'm so glad that's like
the greatest segue,
because watching y'all, it felt
that's what I think
people are gonna love too.
It is very cool how y'all talk about
that you don't always agree
on everything.
- [Hilary] Right.
- And that you learn
from each other that way,
because I think it's very important.
My mother and I, you know,
on some pretty big topics,
we don't go to battle or anything,
but we definitely have different opinions.
Yeah. And I think that,
that it's important.
I love talking about it.
I think, you know what people always say,
and especially in the
South, they'll be like
we don't talk about religion
or politics like that.
We don't do that.
I'm like, those are the people
you should be talking about.
Those are the people you love most,
and you hold in high esteem
and, and I'm wondering like,
what did you learn from your daughter?
- Right. Right.
- Like during this process?
- Well, it's such a good point, Kelly,
because part of what we have
learned, and we want to share
with people is you don't
have to agree with everything
that somebody you meet or know,
or even are related to, believes,
but let's figure out how
to listen to each other.
Let's understand more about
where somebody's coming from.
Let's be more respectful to each other.
And Chelsea knows just so
much stuff about things that,
you know, I don't know very
much about at all, including,
you know, public health cause
she, you know, teaches that.
And so all during COVID I
was learning all the time,
because she was the one
saying, you know, do this,
don't do that.
Yeah. Masks really do matter,
and all the rest of it.
And when we were meeting other people,
and we were out and around
her experience like,
for example, as she said,
we met, you know, Megan
The Stallion and you know,
Chelsea has followed
rap music ever since she
was a teenager.
- Yeah.
- You know, that's new to me.
I mean, I know about it.
There's some people I listened to.
- You did your homework though.
You listened to the music before.
- I did.
I did.
She, she kind of gave me, you know,
- [Kelly] I'm sorry, but-
- Pointers.
- you listening to Megan
Thee Stallion is just
(Hilary cackles)
(audience laughs)
the greatest.
It's the great, I just picture you
with like a drink and just like, yes.
- She said, what?
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- What she just say? Like,
it was like, I love her.
She's she's a Texas girl.
- She also watched the videos.
- Yeah.
(audience gasps)
- Oh! Yeah.
- But that's what I love.
- See, thank you.
I know some of the audiences
is like, oh I know.
Oh yeah.
See the musicians are like, okay.
- No. And that's the thing though.
- I don't think you understand
why that may have been like woohoo,
but you will cause you're
gonna go watch them after this.
- No. And that was what's cool though.
Is that this, that whole part
with her, where y'all are painting.
Like it was like what?
- Yeah.
- It was really cool how there
are all different levels of
of empowerment, and it looks
different for everyone.
- [Chelsea] Amen.
- That is such an important point.
- Amen.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's what y'all made.
- Exactly.
- [Kelly] That was the point. Yeah.
(audience claps)
Today is our hour
dedicated to gutsy women.
We have been talking
about some amazing moments
in their new series on Apple TV Plus
that y'all gotta check out.
It's called Gutsy.
And there was another part too
that made me uncomfortable,
but then I was like,
oh, and it was when you
were with Reverend Whittney
I think was her name.
- Yes.
- And we were talking
and it was an episode
about love and look, it
ain't, it ain't a secret.
It's been a hard few years for me and it,
and I was just like, oh, this
episode, is it gonna kill me?
Should I watch it?
And one of my favorite
moments from the whole
thing was when she just
flat out asked you,
because you had said one
of the gutsiest things,
she'd asked you a question, you said,
hey one of the gutsiest
things I've ever done was
staying in your marriage
when no one expected you to.
- Yeah.
- And so many people, coming from a woman
in the public eye, that goes
through something traumatic
for your own life.
- [Hilary] Hmm.Hmm.
- And then people want to pick
and poke and judge and shame,
and all these things.
It was a really cool thing
that you said for me,
it was gutsy to stay.
- [Hilary] Right.
- And Reverend Whittney said it,
it was gutsy for me to walk away.
- Right.
- I'm just curious, like
how, because I struggle
with it,
and that's why I took
the whole summer off.
Like how do you do that?
- Yeah.
- And you grew up in the
public eye, how do you do this?
Like under a microscope.
Like cause' sometimes I get
overwhelmed by it and it's
and it's your life,
and I thought it was so gutsy
that you said that, you know,
this is, this is my life
and nobody knows my life,
my marriage, my world,
and it was so important for
you to say that because so
many women get shamed for
whatever choice they pick.
- 100%
- Yeah, and you shouldn't.
- [Chelsea] No.
- 100%.
And you know, it, I used to be a very
private person that all ended when I ended
up in public life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I know-
- So fun!
- Because I've, I know,
I know because I've now,
you know, lived a long time.
Everybody goes through something.
I mean relationships, which
are at the core of who you are,
and how you define the
meaning in your life.
Everybody goes through
something, and not everybody,
like you or me, does it in public,
but everybody goes through it.
And so if we can,
and you've done such an important service
in being open and
talking and sharing that,
and so for me to be able to say, look
everybody has to make
the decision that's best
for her or him.
And it's not gonna be the same decision.
It's not the-
- [Kelly] Cause' we're all different
- We're all different.
- And nobody knows the whole relationship,
and the scope of your life.
- Nobody knows,
and, and we need to respect
that if it's a responsible decision.
I mean, we, I, you know,
I, I know people who
you know, they, they can't make a decision
because they're still not
clear in their own heads
how to best manage what they
are in right now and how to get
out of it or how to, you
know, make it better.
But you gotta go through the process.
You can't short-circuit the process.
- Yeah.
- And so when you say, yeah
you've been going through it, you do.
And you know, for me,
it took a lot of, you
know, thought and prayer,
and trusted friends and
confidants to talk to,
and really think through out loud,
and I, you know, I made
the right decision for me.
I have no regrets,
and so I want everybody to feel that way.
And that doesn't mean that it's perfect
cause' no nothing in life is,
but you do the best you
can and then you go on.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that's what we should be looking to.
(audience claps)
- And it was just,
it was one of those things too,
where it's one of those
things where sometimes,
I guess, when you're forced to be in the
in the public eye, or you're in politics,
and all this stuff,
sometimes people don't, they
they confuse the fact that
like, this is a human.
- Yes.
- Like there's humanity there.
- Right.
- Like, you know, and
it, and, and that's okay,
and I think that was
one of the points though
that I was uncomfortable
at first, cause I was like,
why did she ask that?
I was like, I was like so nervous,
but at the same time, it really let me in,
and it was like, oh my
gosh she is like me,
you know, she went through
something that was,
you know, similar in a sense.
And it, and it was just very relatable,
and I didn't, I didn't know,
I didn't really connect
with you on that level until that moment.
And I was like what an important
moment for everyone to see,
cause' we forget in this cancel culture,
that like people are human.
- Right. Right.
- Like we, we, we all have errors.
We all, we all have things that happen
in our lives that are big.
- Yeah.
- You know.
- And I think too, you know,
Kelly, while we all may be
in the public eye in a certain
way, because of social media,
I think particularly young
people, you know, adolescents,
teenagers, even, even kids
who are online are, are also
in a public sphere in a way that was very
different than when I was
a kid or you were a kid.
- I'm so happy I'm not a kid right now.
- [Hilary] It's hard.
- I think that that's also
why these conversations
are so important because
while maybe it's not
someone who would be recognized, you know,
in a different state
or a different country,
it is a kid who may be recognized anywhere
in their hometown or anywhere
where they are, you know
visiting a family member
in that person's hometown,
because of the way people's, you know
social circles and
communities now overlap,
and so I think these candid
conversations are so important.
- Yes.
- Because I think
particularly young people
are having to confront
something, you know,
psychologically, emotionally-
- [Kelly] Advanced.
- That hasn't been true.
Right?
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- Like historically,
like most people have been private people,
and now most people are
are public in some way,
and that's very different,
and so anything that we can do to try
to help create kind of space and grounding
for people to have those
candid conversations
with their trusted friends,
not necessarily, you know
just the people they're connected to
on Instagram, is hopefully also
helpful to at least someone.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience claps)